the Assyrian opposition group is told
Sky News that more than 350 people have
been killed by government forces in the
city of Homs they claim President
Assad's regime carried out a three armed
massacre as the UN Security Council
prepares to vote on a draft resolution
backing calls for him to stand down our
chief correspondent Stewart Ramsay
reports it came in the darkness a
sustained barrage of water and artillery
rounds smashing into districts of Homs
leveling buildings killing and wounding
scores of people we can't verify this
amateur video but we have no reason to
doubt its authenticity
nor the eyewitness reports from inside
the bank booth the a local idiot
district of the city took the brunt of
the attack
the streets reverberating to the sounds
of explosions and gunfire an intense
offensive against a civilian housing
area where opposition is strong you can
hear now the sound of pulling the dead
and injured soon overwhelmed the few
field hospitals set up over the past ten
months to treat people who can't risk
going to the main hospital neighboring
mosques are now being used for triage
and for keeping the bodies of the Dead
it's unclear why such an offensive would
take place as the United Nations
considers a vote condemning the actions
of the Syrian government some think a
sudden wave of army desertions may have
sparked the fighting or that the attack
was an act of retribution
after the Free Syrian Army overwhelmed
the checkpoint and captured these
soldiers then released these pictures of
them being questioned there have been
anti-government demonstrations violence
and deaths in cities and towns across
the country and the word was reserved
for homes if the numbers of dead are
confirmed this will be the worst single
day of violence in nearly 11 months this
could be a turning point for Syria mr.
Ramsay Sky News in the Middle East